[Applause]
i love this is that quartz uh it is it's
quartz i love quartz thank you
somebody's bringing in the good juju i
know somebody told me about cords a long
time ago and i was like look i don't
know if it works or not but i like put
it out by the moon i load it up i do all
the things i mean i'm wearing all the i
know just in case jade it up i do it all
i don't know if it's real or not but it
makes me feel nice
yeah yeah it is if we say it it is if i
say it is as well
we were just talking about um graceland
you live in tennessee right i do i do
i'm in nashville now yeah i have uh as a
matter of fact um i went
when i was on the show we went uh
the show
when we went to we went to graceland
because it was the week
that was the week i got voted off doing
elvis and it was it was the week i was
most proud of i did suspicious minds i'm
like i know this jam and uh
and uh yeah that was that was um so i
got to meet priscilla and wow and it was
it was an incredible experience yeah oh
my god i missed that a couple times and
we're actually getting ready to perform
there they have a venue there now oh
really yeah oh wow see i gotta go check
it i live like in nashville i can't
believe you've ever never i know i can i
work a lot but i but i
but i just yeah i never made it there
and i don't know how i did it but um i
love that you live in nashville it's
such a it's such a great place to like
work and live yes it's a good place for
musicians yes of all different genres i
feel like yeah i have so many friends
there and we never see each other oh my
god that's the biggest joke here for me
yeah everybody's like what are you doing
in your off time and i was like oh
that's a cute term yeah i'm happy bed by
nine o'clock because when you're a
parent you're like um i get home from
work and then i parent so that's what i
do i'm so cool um well you're performing
a song i'm off your album dear leave 11.
and this is your first release is on
your own label yes how does that feel uh
very liberating yeah
to not have anybody's voice but your own
and your and your and your tight circle
of producers and writers that you work
with um yeah it was i wasn't chasing
anything i wasn't trying to write
a radio song or or this or that it was
just like let's write and and that was
such a gratifying experience too i love
it and i'm the most proud of this record
because of it you know oh man i love
that for you as an artist that's really
cool that freedom is cool thank you so
much thanks for having me
time for a break everybody doctor's
latest album is dearly beloved you can
get it right now wherever you get your
music
[Music]
you